american and haitian authorities are
still working to free 17 members of an
american-based missionary group who were
kidnapped in haiti almost three weeks
ago the leader of the kidnappers has
threatened to kill those hostages unless
a 17 million dollar ransom is paid 1
million dollars for each hostage the
white house says that president biden is
briefed on the situation every single
day
former u.s special envoy to haiti daniel
foote meanwhile resigned back in
september to protest the biden
administration's overall haiti policy in
his first interview since resigning foot
told face the nation moderator margaret
brennan why
i realized the only way i'd get the
right attention was by
going nuclear and resilient ambassador
daniel foote's frustrations with what he
calls the biden administration's deeply
flawed haiti policy were mounting when
did you foresee there were problems with
the biden policy
uh
i would say
late august early september what was it
that made you say i can't do this
first
the
del rio texas
bridge situation with 15 000 haitians
i learned about deportations
by the press like everybody else which
was troubling to me due to the pandemic
migrants who illegally enter the u.s are
being expelled without an asylum hearing
seventeen thousand haitians crossed
between september and october over seven
thousand six hundred were sent back
the
haitian state cannot take care of the
people that it currently has and to put
thousands or tens of thousands of
additional desperate people into that
situation is only going to
fuel a terrible situation
the biden administration disputes foot's
version of events but a second state
department official also resigned to
protest the migration policy
migrants are expected to continue
fleeing due to haiti's deteriorating
security after the july assassination of
president johannel moyes this man
arielle henry stepped in as acting prime
minister do you believe the acting prime
minister played a role in the
assassination of president moyes i
can't answer that there are allegations
there are phone records that indicate
that he had several conversations before
and after the assassination with one of
the prime suspects ariel henry has some
questions to answer for his citizenry
henri denies the allegations the state
department says it supports the current
government but wants haitians to decide
their own fate did you ever
propose any kind of military
intervention to haiti i propose sending
a company or so of us special forces to
train
an anti-gang task force within the
national haitian national police so
you're talking about
30 60 people the biden administration
opposes sending troops but gangs are
gaining ground even cutting off the
country's fuel supply and taking
hostages
a group of christian missionaries
including 16 americans are being held by
the gang called 400 mawozo the gangs are
stronger than the police the police are
out gunned and overmatched right now
they need lethal aid they need training
we can give that to them can america
live with a failed haitian state next
door no
i i mean we can but it's going to have a
major negative impact on us
powerful interview there for margaret
brennan